>> Hi everyone. Thank you for coming. The
benefits team is thrilled to welcome Bethenny
Frankel to Google Health and Wellness Week
2009. As an authority on achieving and maintaining
healthy and balanced lifestyle, Celebrity
Natural Food Chef Bethenny Frankel has a knack
for making healthy food taste delicious. Bethenny
attended the National Gourmet Institute for
Health and Culinary Arts and then put her
skills to use by forming her own company,
BethennyBakes which features a line of low
fat, wheat, egg and dairy free baked goods.
Bethenny has gained recognition for her celebrity
clients including Dennis Leary, Alicia Silverstone,
Susan Sarandon, [INDISTINCT], Daisy Fuentes,
Mariska Hargitay and others to name a few.
In addition to her best selling cookbook:
Naturally Thin, Bethenny is the author of
a monthly column in Health Magazine called
Celebrity Diet Secrets. Bethenny talents stand
beyond the kitchen as well. She stars in Bravo's
hit reality series: The Real Housewives of
New York City where she has been acclaimed
for her candor, sharp-wit and humor. Immediately
following the author's talk, Bethenny will
do a book signing and make a guest show appearance
in Hemispheres from one until two. If you
are using your laptops, just please be mindful
that you're not typing very loud and please
silence your cell phones everyone. At the
end of the talk, you'll be able to ask questions
at the standing mikes on the side, this is
for YouTube, so just please make sure that
you speak clearly so she would understand
your questions. That said, please join me
in welcoming Bethenny Frankel.
>> FRANKEL: Hi. Okay, first of all, the only
one who looks like she works here is my assistant,
Molly, with like cargo pants and a sweatshirt.
What the hell is up with all that Alice and
Olivia dresses and all the girls. You don't
understand that I'm more scared to be here
than like when I was talking with Ted Turner
at NYU because I'm like people are standing
in the hall holding computers while they're
standing up. They're not even on a desk, this
is psychotic. I don't even how to Twatter
or Twitter or whatever, this is fucked up.
I thought, I'm not kidding. And first of all,
you guys like have like M&Ms flowing. You
guys are all hopped up on chocolate, you can't
have Skinnygirl Margaritas in the middle of
the day? I mean, it's five o'clock somewhere,
so this is like a very big learning experience
for me. And who are these three nerds somewhere
else that are watching, look at them. Come
here. Hi. He's like, oh, my God. Hi. Hi. Hi.
Do they work for Pixar or they just like obsessed
with Pixar? I'm not even kidding, I am so
excited. And, does everybody Google each other
at their desks, by the way? Does everybody--let
me find any other information about each while
you're at your desk like Googleing each other?
Or is like all canceled each other out there
and there's something else that you do? Like
nerdy spies coming down the hall. All right.
I am at Google and here we are. So, anyway,
who hates Kelly Bensimon just like star--no
offense, I just like to talk about really
important things. I do happen to have written
a book, but I know that no one gives a shit
about that even though it has been on the
New York Times bestsellers for 18 weeks but
we can talk about that after; we can gossip
about the show. I look like a bigger nerd
than anyone here. Look at me in my--yeah,
whatever. All right, the next time, I'm coming
in a stripper's outfit because I didn't get
it, I understand. Hi. Hi. He looks like the
perfect customer to be carrying my book. Have
you unleashed your Skinnygirl? You don't,
you're in the process of unleashing your Skinnygirl.
Right. All right. So--what are you guys doing
on the computers, are you taking notes? Or,
video--what's happen--seriously, what is happening
with the computers in here? What? You could--oh,
that's why they feed you all day, you can't
leave, you have to work while you're in these
meetings. Honestly, I didn't know if it was
like some sort of like, like, like what a
breakfast in bed thing, just leaning things
on it. All right. Okay, and Molly and most
of the Mac people, so you should happy. All
right. So, who wants to gossip about the show
first? Questions about the show, that's open
for complete discussion, anybody?
>> Are you going back for the next season?
>> FRANKEL: I am coming back for the next
season. I'll be back in September. I will
not be the single girl anymore, I have a boyfriend
so, finally. [INDISTINCT]. Yes, who is he?
He's name is Jason, Jason 2, we call him Jason
Sequel. Yes. As, Lori, my publicist likes
to say, the only Jason I haven't slept with
is the one from Friday the 13th because he's
a little scary but, the night is young. Yeah.
I don't, I literally dated four Jasones since
Jason. If anyone's name is Jason here, pull
your pants down. I'm just saying because it
could happen at Google. All right. So, that's
that. Any other inappropriate questions--oh,
hopefully, no one has any problem with inappropriate
that's usually the disclaimer in the beginning
and there's no small children here so that
I know is fine. So, if anyone has any problem
with inappropriateness, please, there's the
Google door. Questions? About the show--we
can talk about the book after.
>> If Kelly is crazy, she'd beat you [INDISTINCT]?
>> FRANKEL: Yeah, well, I mean, I've only
ever spent time with her when you've seen
it on the show. Yeah, I think there's something
at, very, very wrong with her. I do think
she's missing a part of her brain like I'm
not even--I think there's something wrong
with her. She's just not playing with a full
deck. So, and she tries to like, I'm just
like, don't, don't do it. Don't listen, this
mouth is like fire. Don't, don't, just let's
not talk because if you speak to me and you
try to be smart and you try to make people
like you, it's not going work, so, she's a
total, see you next Tuesday.
>> Who are you most in touch with in the show?
>> FRANKEL: I'm the most in touch with Jill,
I'd say. Jill and I have had a relationship
the whole entire time. I'm not that--I think
Kelly is my best friend this season. I'm not
that in touch with anybody. I mean, I've been
working. I've been on the book tour and the
truth is--it's very toxic. It's extremely
toxic and stressful because you know me laying
in my bed, sleeping isn't exactly interesting,
so they want to see like, if you took any
six girls in any high school, in any town,
anywhere, it would be a cat fighting and I'm
not really that kind of girly-girl. I do Skinnygirl
Margaritas by myself at home. Not really out
with like many girl, I'm not that girl. So,
it's been challenging, it's been difficult
and the first season having a boyfriend who
wanted no part of it and then, you know, subsequently
getting him fired was a little stressful.
So, you know, maybe Jason 2 will keep his
job. But the show's, you know, it's been the
best thing I've ever done in my entire life.
I didn't want to do it in the beginning, I
turned it down for two months and they'd already
been shooting and I kept sort of thinking
about it and it was like a gamble because
the show then was called Manhattan Moms. I
didn't know what it was going to be. I thought,
you know, everyone be just drunk with like
tassels on their titties, standing, dancing
and my career would be ruined because I have
just started with a Health Magazine and Pepperidge
Farm, so. And I had already written my book
but not gotten it published; so I was very
nervous, and now, I mean, it was the best
thing I ever did, it really was. It was like,
it was like a complete launching pad so, and
got laughs. So, that's that part of it.
>> How much of what we see is influenced by
the producers and writers versus what you
guys want to represent?
>> FRANKEL: Well, it's funny. The--I know
I always make a food analogy, but like people
will say like I don't like greens or I don't
like lettuce and there's a rugula and there's
iceberg, there's a million different types,
that's the same thing with reality shows.
I can see when I'm watching The Hills that
that is completely like there are people with
earpieces telling them what to do. Our show,
as real as it can be with the exception of
where we're shooting like, if I wanted to
shoot today, I'm going to be at Google, they
might, they probably won't let, well, you
know, Big Brother around here, you definitely
wouldn't--they definitely wouldn't let me.
But, but, so, I'll be like I want to go, we're
going on a date to Le Cirque and I'll be like
we can't shoot there so you have to go, you
know, Joaquain's Mexican Restaurant or whatever.
And so, that, but what happens there, they'll
also might be like we want to see, you know,
we want to hear about what happened with you
and Jason last week. You know, with the domestic
violence argument, I'm just kidding. So, then
we'll start talking about it, but if whatever
comes out of our mouths really does come out
of our mouths. I mean, I could see at Atlanta
and these other shows which are different
production companies, they do a lot for the
drama. They do, I mean, I really don't think
that woman would have put that table on Jersey,
had it not been dramatic. But, it all did
really happen, no and said flip the table,
so there are shows really real. Oh, no, she's
a producer, oh, you said, writers?
>> For both, yeah.
>> FRANKEL: Oh, no one's writing anything.
No, could you write this stuff, no one's writing
anything. No one's writing anything. Oh, no.
They, they just, you know, you find crazy
people, I mean, myself included. You find
crazy people and you put six crazy people
together and crazy things will happen. And
people get--I'm, you know, hmmm, I act exactly
like myself and I always tell like it is.
I mean, would I have loved to have slapped
the shit out of Kelly, I would have. It would
have been fun just to be like, you know what,
don't fuck yourself you self-involved star
fucking bitch. But I didn't say that because
somewhere in the back of my head I know what's
going on and I now building a brand and I
know
I have a New York Time best seller that's
going to come out and so, you know, a little
bit, I would love to rip someone's weave off,
you know. I would, I would, I mean, I really
but I had it in my life but I would like to
do it but I mean there are some resemblance
of order that I feel like I need to maintain,
but that's within life too. I'd love to rip
someone weave off in a book signing when they,
they're like a stalker crazy person but I
don't do that either and the cameras aren't
on so, that's security.
>> Two things that you have mentioned, yeah,
finding crazy, the six crazy, you know, or
whatever, how did they find you all?
>> FRANKEL: And also when I say six... I'm
sorry.
>> Do you think--is that when you get in,
do you watch other reality shows [INDISTINCT]?
>> FRANKEL: Yes. I love Atlanta more than
our show. I mean, did anybody see the last
show where they fight [ph]? Round check me,
boo. I mean, that was crazy. I mean, I want
to be in their show but I also want to be--listen,
they'll all be like, you are a racist because
I'll be like, yeah, who, I'm working my weave
even though I don't have a weave but I like
saying it, I think it's funny. Why a white
woman can't say "working my weave?" but I
do anyway. I want to be in Atlanta. I want
to be like, I'm going go get pooky and I'm
coming over and whup your ass. I mean, that
is not something a white woman says and I
want to be in that show. So, yes, I watch
them all and I blog and they're all scared
of what I'm going to say because I rip them
new ones, and I love it. I love to blog. They
picked us also by saying six crazy women and
if I took any six of you and mixed you up,
you guys would all kill each other and talk
about each other, everything. It's just like
that movie: "Liar, Liar" with Jim--who is
it, Jim Carrey? This guy, say what you want,
what would you think, you know? I'm like Ramona,
you are bat shit crazy, I wouldn't say that
if I were a normal friend in normal life and
I was like in her wedding party. That's a
beautiful wedding dress, I love this bridesmaids
dress. But on the show it's like that is disgusting.
So you kind of say a little more, but they
found--everybody, mostly in the Hamptons,
it's funny, most people I know have met their
husbands in the Hamptons and they found us
in the Hamptons and I was a complete happy
accident to them. They wanted a wife, they
wanted someone who had kids and this is totally
not kosher when a producer would hang out
with one of the castmates. So they, one of
them, Jill, they had already found and they
were like we are screwed because this wasn't,
this was called Manhattan Moms. The show wasn't
a success and it had no budget. They were
going to get pulled, and Bravo wanted to pick
Housewife so the producer, we have to find
a housewife and Jill said, well, that'd [INDISTINCT],
it's going to [INDISTINCT] hands, it's a [INDISTINCT]
find somebody there and I was there, and I
have a boyfriend, I have no kids, I'm the
farthest thing from a housewife which is what
they wanted and Jill saw me, she's like, "Oh,
my God, you skinny bitch. I'm doing a show;
you have to meet the producers." And, I met
the producers and it was like they just asked
me if they could take me which they did and
then I said, no, and then two months later,
they still hadn't found the person. So, for
me, I wasn't even supposed to be at [INDISTINCT]
that day, it was completely really meant to
be for me. So they found everybody, now, they
make it like a nationwide casting call like
when I was in the Apprentice, it's not like
that. With us, it wasn't like that. With us,
we're just lucky that they picked because
they would have picked anybody off the tray
at that point. So, that was that--that was
the whole question, right? Okay. Cool. Anyone
else?
>> Is your favorite restaurant, you are really
Felipe [ph] [INDISTINCT]?
>> FRANKEL: No. My favorite--I like Felipe
[ph], I like Felipe [ph] because they put
Skinnygirl Margarita on the menu and that
was where it was born. People always me my
favorite restaurant and I can never really
think. I like [INDISTINCT] a lot because it's
like that's ala carte, I like steakhouses,
I like the Strip House, I think it's a sexy
steakhouse. I like Anjo's [ph] in Mulberry.
I'm not like a fancy food person. I like sort
of down home food. Am I going to be invited
back to Google ever again? I'm just curious
because sorry, man, I didn't take my meds
this morning and I'm just saying shit.
>> [INDISTINCT]?
>> FRANKEL: No, got it. Okay. Yeah, and they
do, they YouTube themselves. Yeah, so. They
like--oh, no, Google everybody. All right.
So, anyone has read the book that I happen
to have written?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you help us about Ramona first before
you...?
>> FRANKEL: Oh, Ramona, sure. What do you
want to know?
>> If she really is [INDISTINCT] crazy as?
>> FRANKEL: Ramona. Ramona. Ramona has like
that switch that just, just she'd be like,
"Hey, oh, my God. Hi, it's nice to see you."
And you'd be like, "Why are we doing that?
I don't understand why we're doing that. We
don't want to do that, I didn't sign up for
that." Ramona, this switch just goes off but,
I would say just add Ramona. She was like
red pepper flakes. You just, if you put it
in a recipe sometimes, it just makes it just
spicy enough like Penne Arrabiata but sometimes
it's like, you know, she's, Ramona is nuts,
we're all sort of nuts when [INDISTINCT] not
particularly crazy when she is like a low
grade...? What?
>> What about
the [INDISTINCT]?
>> FRANKEL: The countess is very cool. I think
the countess got caught up a lot in her countess
mess. The first two seasons and like was sitting
behind that whole thing but, she, I've been
out with countess and she's pretty, she's
pretty cool when it comes down to it. "Darling,
you better lean into a man and be a damsel
in distress." Yeah, I mean, the countess is,
she's caught up in the countessness. But now
she's, well, she's still the countess. She's
countless but she a count--yeah, the countess
is no count. So, I like [INDISTINCT] well,
we get along really well. Had we both been
single at the same time back in the day, it
would have been ugly, yeah. Alex is very nice--Alex
is very, very--who just asked that? Oh, Alex
is very, Alex is nice, she's harmless, she's
very, you know, you need Simon--it really
need to be Silex because you need—I'm sorry?
>> No ID picture?
>> FRANKEL: It's funny you asked, I don't--there
were doing a sign up for a parenting show.
I'm not kidding like on getting your kids
into school in Manhattan. Oh, all of us are
sort of a happy accident in a way except Jill,
who was like right in the middle of if all.
But, they signed up for like getting your
kids into school, a parenting show, and I
think, yeah, you'd call it a team. I think,
we had her and they need him, I mean not any
other husbands are men are in the show. I
really wouldn't want someone--I don't want,
you know, a Tori & Dean kind of situation
coming up, you know, but this is just too
weird but, you need both of them, you really,
really do. And they have their own like cult
following now I think.
>> So there is the last season, you mentioned
[INDISTINCT] running down... Because like
the most difficult thing you've ever...
>> FRANKEL: Everything is unbelievable with
her.
>> And, it was just certainly that, just Kelly
saying, "Hey," like [INDISTINCT], let's do
it. You could mean running in the traffic.
>> FRANKEL: Well, cartwheels are free. So,
running in front of the course in carriage,
yeah it's kind--that's like what happens if
I would do like "Yehey." Like it's just, it's
so--the thing is it is so--listen to I'm speaking
to who has, who ever speaks this way to anyone
much less everyone? You know, I don't have--she,
she has her own thing it's just she's very--I
don't know I think she really--she's a girl
who is a wealthy girl, lives in a big house
and I think she really wants everyone to like,
I think that she's really like Boheme and
in Birkenstocks with the whole, you know,
the pick up truck and like I'm just free and
that, you know, like I said cartwheels are
free--we are just so opposite. I can't even--it's
like an--I can't even comment, I don't even
know. We just do not gel. It's not for T.V.
I've been--we just don't, I'm just like I
don't--I don't get it. I've never seen the
likes of this before…
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRANKEL: I think she's coming back, I mean
to my--I haven't seen--to my knowledge she'll
be coming back and then everyone's going to
want the whole me and her; I'll do it for
pay per view. For pay per view, I feel like
for a good amount of money which I actually
think people would pay to me see like mud
wrestle her in pay per view. And I seriously
have thought about it and I think like even
the people--I've been to Mall of America and
they've heard me someone inappropriate, I
think people can handle mud wrestling with
Kelly and I think I would win, I would, because
I'm scrappy. So, anyway, this is my little
personal fantasy, but back to reality at Google.
>> Of all the relationships on the show, it's
just like [INDISTINCT] the most authentic
friendship?
>> FRANKEL: Yeah, that's the most true, that's
the most authentic friendship, it's true,
it's true.
>> How did you guys met each other and...
>> FRANKEL: We met, you know, Jill makes,
makes it her business to meet everybody. And
so we met at a movie premiere--well, actually
we met a couple of times and I really didn't
know her that well until that day at Polo
[ph], like until the show, we did really get
to know each other and to get to know our
family and, and things like that. And she
was sort of my closest person on the show,
it's just a weird experience to go through,
and so you need someone to--to kind of be
going through with. But since--excuse me--since
I have a boyfriend, since I've been really
caught up in the book and I just wrote the
second book, I've kind of been--I haven't
been really hanging out with anybody, I've
just been working. So, it will be interesting--it
will be really fresh when we get back to shooting
because I haven't really seen--I didn't even
seen Jill that much this summer, she's traveling
and I've been traveling so, it will be spicy,
it will be interesting. I don't think it could
be as interesting as Atlanta or other shows,
I just don't, I don't think any of this would
go with there and it would be sort of fun
if we did like the un-, you know, the unplugged
version of Real Housewives in New York but
it's just not the same.
>> Who do you think is crazier, [INDISTINCT]?
>> FRANKEL: That's a great question. Who do
I think is crazy--or Kelley--or is this funny
that you guys to do work? Would your bosses
just drop dead? Would they just be like this
is what you're talking about? They don't even
know who Kelly or Danielle are or they might…
>> They're here.
>> FRANKEL: What?
>> They're probably here.
>> FRANKEL: They're probably here? Oh, they're
here, you mean? Oh, are you--or the bosses--who
are the bigwigs here, raise your hands, they
wouldn't even admit it. I'll Google, I'll
figure out later. Kelly or Danielle? Danielle
is like—oh, let's see, that's a better match
than me and Kelly. They're equally pathological
I think, I think they're equally. I think
Danielle is a--is the biggest—no, they're
the same, they're the same person. Bigger
tits, bigger lips, but same person, I can't
answer that. Best question of the day, thank
you. No, it's some to me, some to me.
>> Okay. It seem like the second season there
is a lot more like the charity work, involvement
[INDISTINCT] that you guys are put up to not
necessarily you but...?
>> FRANKEL: It's a good--it's funny, it's
funny, it's a good question. And it's, in
all the Housewives things, I mean everyone
needs to make themselves feel really important
or have to like explain to the world why they're
doing a reality show. They make it like we're
all in Malawi on our knees like, you know,
like hugging babies. And, you know, I work
with different charities and I'm not saying
I'm on my knees in Malawi either. I work with
the ASPCA or the humane society and donate
my time and donate cooking and things but,
everybody really feels that even in all the
shows to be like "I do so much charity." I
think kind of charity is the kind of thing
you're doing it, you don't really need to
be yelling it out at the top of your lungs.
The one big charity event, they kind of didn't
want us to do something together, and so Jill's
friend had us do that charity, we all get
back together on it. But that kind of, you
know, at the end, they gave us all of these
awards but I was like I don't need an award.
It just felt a little, it felt a little inauthentic
like we're all getting an award, a glass award
made my Mario from true, you know, religion
or true faith trophies. So, you know, I just
felt, I felt--everyone was like hawking their
stuff, myself included but, that was a little
pushing it, so. My cookbook, book. Okay, so
now where I become a human being for a minute.
So "Naturally Thin" is my book which I wrote
not because I ever wanted to be an author,
I didn't. I mean, I've always have a knack
for writing. I've always like to writing articles,
I loved writing assignments but I never wanted
to be a writer or an author. I came from a
very, very toxic household, a very, very toxic
family with alcoholism and chain smoking and
living in 13 different places, going to 13
different schools, and there was an obsession
coming from my mother and father just in the
whole--my whole family background, obsession
with food. And food where I call the book
food noise, and dieting, and you can't be
fat and you have to be thin. And, basically,
I spent my whole life, probably since--no,
my whole entire life, I mean since I could
probably read or know what even, you mean,
I talk a lot about parents not saying diet
in front of their kids or not like making
that obsession of their own passing it on
and that's a lot of what the book is about.
But, basically, I've spent most of my life
completely obsessed with dieting and being
thin and ripping out every single diet in
every single magazine and reading all the
charts and it could be anything from Better
Homes and Gardens to Seventeen and always
being on a diet, the Scarsdale Diet, the Atkins
Diet, the Southbeach Diet, the [INDISTINCT],
the this, the that, the nonsense. And, probably,
for most of my like, you know, from high school
to college, adult life to early 30s, I was
always like 20 -25 pounds heavier than I am
now, and I would have been 90 pounds heavier
had I not been completely obsessed, spinning
and stepping and exercising every day and
always like I was good because I ate this,
I was bad because I ate that. And, I never
was bulimic, I never was anorexic but, it
definitely was a like a disorder because it
was a complete obsession and I know so many
people go through this, and, but it was my
own sort of secret thing. I mean some of my
girlfriends they're like I was so bad today,
I can't believe, but I ate them, I'm going
to be good tomorrow. Monday was always the
big day to diet or the day after the big binge
then you need diet. And it's just was like
completely, completely shackling. It was like
being in prison, and as an evolution it just
became more and more tiring and you get better,
better at the dieting because you, you know,
you know more so I've been, being a natural
food chef, you know were about like whether
it's tofu or vegetarian or steamed and fasts,
and all these like excuses like the Gwyneth
Paltrow thing. This is, the whole thing about
Gwyneth Paltrow, she like overdetoxing or
over--because a lot of people do the whole
bullshit of pretending it's in the guise of
like being healthy but it's still really obsessive.
So, that was that whole phase of that being
a natural food chef. And, about, probably,
my early, it was in my early 30s, I was going
on trip to Italy where I'd been several times
before, and Mario Vitali had given a friend
of mine a bunch of different of restaurants
that I had to go visit in Venice and I just--I
was going with a boyfriend, I was like I'm
done. I've had so many trips where I've gone
to Italy and it's been like torture the server
if they can't find the skim milk somewhere
in Italy. Go beat up some Italian at some
Italian market, find me some freakin' skim
milk or Equal or whatever. which is so psycho
because like a teaspoon of sugar is, you know,
whatever some few calories--no one ever got
fat of on a bit of cream or small cappuccino,
but it's just this like this whole food noise
obsession. And I was like this is a trip where
I'm going to just eat the vegetable Antipasto
the whole time because that's what I'm allowed
to eat, and this is a trip where I'm going
to just come back, my jeans are going to be
the same. And all the rules in this book which
I call a toolbox because you could use the
hammer and you could use the screwdriver,
there's no plan, you don't need to know everything.
It's the kind of book that you just read and
it just becomes part of you. But all of the
rules were born in Italy and some of the--one
of the rules--the big overriding rules is
your diet is a bank account. And so, basically,
just like the economy, just like shopping,
just like buying an impractical sequined dress
or something. After you do that, you should
buy nothing or buy a cashmere sweater. When
you have your money, finances--some of us
are in debt, some of us aren't, I've been
there. I've bounced more checks than I even
care to explain. You don't carry your checkbook
around during the day. You know when you've
gone out and you shop and you bought something,
you have a little bit of remorse about it
that you know you went over. And then you
know that if you're not going to buy something
next, that's the whole thing about your diet
and the bank account. And the problem with
most diets is that they are cookie cutter
and people's lives are not cookie cutter.
People are business travelers, people are
at mini-marts, people have no money; they
have to go to McDonalds. The book is about
whatever your own life is and being able to
be Latin and keep rice and beans in your life.
Or, you know, just be Italian and you want
to eat pasta because we've gone through the
days where pasta was the devil, and avocado,
and sushi used to be the devil to me and all
these things that we've been forbidden, and
in the book, the book doesn't tell you there's
no, there is no no. There's only yes, it's
just how? And so, your diet is a bank account
would be the overriding rule, and then there
are other little rules like the hammer and
the screwdriver and you know, the magnet ruler
or whatever, and those are like taste everything,
eat nothing. So, that's the kind of rule that
you'd bring out if you're at a buffet or at
a Superbowl party or at someone's wedding.
That's when you're like, you know what those
cube neon cheese, cheeses I've seen it a million
times, I don't need to eat that but you know
what, they have caviar here, they have coconut
shrimp, so I'm going to have a little bit
of it all; the same kind of thing if you're
on a date and you're in a fattening restaurant,
you don't want to be that person that's just
like "Oh, I can't have this or I can't have
that," all the noise. The book makes it into
a voice and it gives you a good relationship
with food, and people often ask me "What's
the most important rule?" and they're all
important and they're all made to be broken
except for the check yourself before you wreck
yourself rule, and that is--I used to be the
girl that'd go out Marquee, I'd be single,
I'd get drunk. I'd come home four in the morning,
I'd go to that deli that, that fortunately
is now is closed, The Bodega. I swear to God,
the chef from La Bodega was from Le Cirque,
he was so amazing. They just close it, they
couldn't pay the rent, we're all mourning
on this side of the room but it's okay. So,
anyway, I used to go in there and get coffee
cake, and get ice cream, and get chips, and
like because you're ruining yourself. You're
like it's over, it's going to be good tomorrow
and I'm going to ruin myself. And that's a
binge, that's the only thing that you cannot
break that rule because that's emotional,
it has nothing to do with actual hunger. You
would never be hungry enough to eat like that.
You wake up swollen with like a food hangover
and you hate yourself and it wreaks havoc
on your body and that is the one only rule
that you can't break. It doesn't mean you
can't have fried chicken, it doesn't mean
that you cannot have potato chips, it just
mean you can't go off the rail like Ramona
at a dinner party, you can't go off the rail.
You can't lose your mind and do something
so crazy that people would still be talking
at Google two years later. And so there are
other things in the book like the point of
diminishing return where, you know, you have
a plate of fried calamari and you have a bite
and it's amazing and you have another bite,
it's amazing. And then it starts to not get
amazing and it starts to get really like you're
so, have such anxiety about the fact that
you're eating fried calamari or a cheese burger
that now it goes in the other direction. You
kind of like a little self-loathing. That's
when you stop because it's never going to
get any better and there will be another fried
calamari, there will be another French fries
and there are all these little things in the
book like that like the differential--for
me Turkey chili is just as good as regular
chili, like it's not worth the extra fat,
for somebody else that might be something
else. But, for me I don't want a piece of
grilled chicken or broiled steam piece of
chicken, I want a fatty New York steak, so
that's where I decide to invest. And the book
talks about good investments and bad investments,
and but it's individual for every single one
of you, so the book is just something you
read, you don't like flip to some chart and
rip it out. Just read it, it becomes part
of you. You absorb it, you trust it, you know
hundreds and thousands of people have lost
like 50, 60, 70 pounds now and I don't know,
it's been out since March 10th. And this has
been like the, the baby of my life. I'm excited
about the Skinnygirl Margarita, that's going
to put my kids' kids through college, it's
all good. But the book--it is, we're ripping
off copies, the sign on the back in his yacht
and we're going, and we're going to have margaritas
flowing out of the faucets and all kinds of
plans for that because that's going to be
major. But, the book, this book is the one
great thing that I've done in life because
it's changing people's lives, like people
with eating disorders are sending me letters.
Their husbands are saying that their wives
will finally eat foods that their kids could
eat. That their wife will get pregnant again
because she was afraid of getting fat, I mean,
people have fucked up noise about food. So,
they really do because you have to live with
it, it's not like drugs, you can't get rid
of it, or alcohol you can't get rid of it,
not that you'd ever want to. But, food you
have to keep in your life, and the book is,
you know, is pretty good, so, read the book.
>> Just the one issue where...
>> Microphone.
>> FRANKEL: Are we doing microphone--mam I
on the microphone? Do I need to be on a microphone?
Oh, no, I'm on a microphone.
>> You are. [INDISTINCT] they won't be on
YouTube because they're not using the microphone.
>> It's true, I mean...
>> FRANKEL: Okay, who's the techie who's going
to take off the...?
>> So, one thing that I think people struggle
with is feeling full and a lot of people don't
know what that means anymore. So, you can
say satiated, or whatever, but a lot of thing,
people, I think, struggle with understanding
their body and their body's reaction to food
and when are they full, when are they stuffed?
When are they still hungry and things like
that? So, that's my first question, just how
you've dealt with that over time? And then,
my second question is your decision to call,
sort of your empire, Skinnygirl because that
is...
>> FRANKEL: The word skinny.
>> The word skinny is somewhat controversial
in our society and I, I'm just wondering how
that came about for you?
>>FRANKEL: The first question--do you have
any other question? Okay, the first question
is about being full and it's a great question
because for so long, you know, a part of this
whole food noise, you have such anxiety while
you're eating. We just know to finish our
whole plate, and there's a rule, you know,
cancel your membership to the clean plate
club which involves broccoli or even chicken
broth. Like it's not that you should only
leave food on your plate if it's something
really fattening, it's about just starting
to understand what it means to leave it and
it's okay. You probably know, you've probably
been really busy and you have a whole sandwich
and you eat half and you run off. You're never
missing that other half, you're not starving,
it's just that it was in front of you and
then that's where the anxiety comes from what's
in front of you and not understanding how
to deal with that. And part of it is, it's
not going to happen in the first day because
you--it's mostly anxiety based. Once you start
to get to know yourself, there are little
side rules, like, chew your food slowly, not
obsessively counting bites so that it'd be
[INDISTINCT], but chew your food slowly. Also
paying attention when, you know, you're driving
or you're walking or something and you're
eating; you don't even know what you're doing,
and then you finish and then you're full.
Or, sometimes if you're not eating slowly
enough, you're actually involved in a conversation,
or making a special moment, you get really
full before you even know it and afterwards
you feel like you're full. But, just to know
when you're comfortable that does take a little
bit of practice, it does take not having anxiety
about what you're eating, because you're,
okay, I did it. And there is that moment,
what I could a little more and I could do
a little more, but you kind of have to have
not noise about it, but that food voice about
it and it's an internal conversation about
it which will involve several other rules.
Is it worth it? Is it a good investment? Is
it the point of diminishing return and not
for any of these to be obsessive? I'm saying
it all once, it becomes something you just
understand. When you read the book, you won't
even ask because you'll just understand because
there's so many different situations I explained.
How I feel about when I'm eating something?
How I feel--why I ate something? Why I was
hung over and ate just watermelon or hot chocolate
for breakfast which no book would ever say
to do? Just, the more that you allow yourselves
to have the things that you really want, the
more that you will have anxiety about it.
So, what happens if you eat a piece of chocolate
cake, it's Paris Hilton is a perfect example
of a person, she doesn't give a crap, she
eats half a cheeseburger or French fries and
she walks away because it's not that important,
she can eat another cheeseburger if she wanted
to, but she doesn't want to. Someone called
me up the other day and said, "When I'm 65,
I'm going to eat whatever I want. I'm going
to eat a whole tray of lasagna and I'm just
going to throw caution to the wind," and I
was like, if you say your allowed to, you'll
never going to eat a whole tray of lasagna.
So, it's just something that sort of becomes
part of you. Just something instinctive, that
is what the food voice is. And as far as the
word Skinnygirl, it's very specific that it's
one word, skinnygirl, as oppose to, I always
mention Banana Republic because years ago--you
know, even company Apple, you don't think
of an actual apple, it's just its own word
now. So, Skinnygirl--but it's also, it's not
skinny bitch and I'm not saying anything about
that book, I'm just saying it's not skinny
bitch, it's that--it's a girl, it's a skinny
girl. A girl usually means somebody a little
bit youthful, a little bit nice, and the word
Skinnygirl means the girl that you want to
be, that you're comfortable being. And that
could be, you know, Rihanna or Kim Kardashian,
or a role model who has like, you know, who's
a little, who's not some skinny, skinny bone.
I'm trying to make Skinnygirl--and I'm succeeding
in making Skinnygirl. The girl that can live
and be flirty and in the kitchen and not stressed
out about it and have some, have a cheeseburger,
and have some of the French fries, and have
a Skinnygirl Margarita and not have noise
about it. It's not about some bone, you know
real bone or bone real, or whatever, bone
rail thin, real thin person. It's about the
girl that you felt comfortable being, and
I do think that a lot of these you know, J-Lo
and Beyonce role models are good because they're
hot, and they're a little bigger and they're
healthy and they just own it and they wear
what they want, and it's fitted, and they're
kind of just like, those are girls to me.
So, that's what a Skinnygirl is.
>> Hi, just before I ask my question, I wanted
to say I bought your book actually a week
ago, it's ironic because now we're getting
it for free. But, I made your banana oatmeal
cookies and the Vegan Chili which were awesome
by the way. You guys should try them, I give
them to my family and we're vegetarians, it
was great.
>> FRANKEL: Thank you.
>> You mentioned in your book that you went
to an obesity camp, or an obesity or doctor...
>> FRANKEL: A clinic, an obesity clinic. Right.
>> Right, because your mom was freaking out...
>> FRANKEL: Right.
>> And, so I wanted to know how that affected
you because I think like there wasn't much
mentioned about it, but it was kind of like
an important--you could notice in the book
that it's like an important time in your life.
>> FRANKEL: Definitely.
>> And what exactly they said? How that changed
you? I mean did you, you know, like stop having
like whole milk or something after that, like
what exactly happened?
>> FRANKEL: Yeah, it's funny, yeah, that was
the first, I mean, I think I was eight years
old and that there was something an eight
year old should know about calories and I
think it's interesting because this book,
you know, even I was, I as shooting something
with Isaac Mizrahi that day, he was like,
Well, you know, well, the, this jelly bean
is like one point, how many points does that
chip have? And you know, this whole point
system, you can't even be enjoying what you're
doing. And I just think that for a kid at
eight years old already knows what a calorie
is, and so, I don't even know what those diet
pages are, I'm going to ripping them out.
Is this completely obsessive, and it just
starts off for this whole--so many people
do it, so many people know it. I started earlier,
but I was in nightclubs at 14, so I started
everything earlier. But, to be knowing about
things like that, at that age, it's just,
it's just a lot of food noise. If, I have
friends who have heavy kids, you know, I hear
all it all the time. Like, you know, mothers,
you know--well, if you didn't eat that, you
would fit into this. And it's really, it's
like not the kind of--that's not good tough
love. Food is such a sensitive thing, and
you have to like ease into it, and sometimes
you have to--I don't even have girlfriends
that like, just allow yourself to eat and
be, have a better relationship with food and
then the weight will eventually come off.
It doesn't have to be something--it took your
whole life to gain it, it's going to take,
you know, a little bit to get it off. It's
the kind of thing that you just wanted to
get the sort of mental problem, or mental
noise gone before you start worrying about
it because the obsession will just constantly
go up, go down, that's why people lose weight
on diets. Blame the diet when it comes back,
and then they go to another diet. And, you
just can't be like a counter and so, it definitely
was way too early for a person to even know
about calories. I don't believe in calories,
I don't believe in weighing yourself which
all that is about. Because then, you know
you drink a glass of water or you eat like
you know, a soy bean and you're swollen. I
mean, I have a weight, I never weight myself.
If I'm in some spa away, you know, one out
of six months, I'll weigh myself, but I just
think, it's a bad way to go, and I hate when
kids said that they're going to fat camp.
My friend she wants to send her kid a Skinnygirl
t-shirt because she sent her to the fat camp,
and I'm like, that sounds great, to send a
Skinnygirl t-shirt to a fat camp. So, you
know, it's just, a lot of it and if I again--speaking
about charities, that kind of charity that
I want to work in, is developing a healthy
relationship with food for younger girls,
for teens. I think that's a huge, huge area,
a sensitive area. So, I was even--so, you're
right, it was very, it's something I remember,
shouldn't have been there.
>> My question is more about being a vegetarian
because a lot of diets and I guess not even
diets, but just eating in general is so much
focused around meat or high protein or any
of those things...
>> FRANKEL: yeah.
>> Being a vegetarian and trying to be vegan
it's just really hard...
>> FRANKEL: I think that the way that a lot
of people find out if they're allergic to
things is through like the food elimination
diet. Sort of which means either you would
start on a fast, or you start just eating
sort of healthy for a week or so, and then
adding things back in. I'm getting somewhere,
I know you asked a sort of different question,
but there's a reason I'm saying this. And
you kind of realize that you react on things.
Ironically, I've done raw, I've done vegan,
and I've done everything and I had, I really
don't have any food allergies. But as of late,
I realized that when I have this soy milk
in my Starbucks' coffee that I just start
to feel like kind of congested, and like feel
like I could have more glamorous word slimy.
And so, I realized when I cut that out, that
I'm allergic to that. I think that if people
have food intolerances is like wheat can make
him more bloating, you should start paying
attention to how you feel. And that's how
you should eliminate and decide whether you're
going to be vegan or raw or vegetarian. But
I don't, you know, I don't believe in the
books that tell you what you should be, you're
supposed to this. And that is an ethical issue
and I completely understand the ethical issue,
I really do. If you see this movie, Food Inc.,
which is coming out, you'll never want to
eat again. And also, I love animals, so I
am conflicted of the fact that I do like to
eat steak, then where do you draw the line
if I will wear a leather purse but I won't
wear fur. And, I am definitely--you can't
do everything, I'm inflicted about organic
and trying to teach people what things to
eat that are organic because not everyone
can afford it. I mean there's a lot of information,
but I think that everyone's body is different.
And I mean my boyfriend would say, "How come
one of you wants a health food store, everybody
who works there is green," you now, because
all of the people always like green. Everyone
just looks, I don't mean like green, yay we're
being environmental, I mean they look green.
And I'm like I don't know, maybe it's because
I'm not eating any meat. I mean I'm not a
doctor, but I think that you know when you
kind of have that like those black circles,
and then when you're missing something. And
girls know when you're getting a period if
you want some red meat that there's like a
reason, you're craving something. I think
you have to get kind of in touch with your
body and know what it needs and know what
it doesn't need, and work it out for yourself.
And some people for digestion reasons do better
with vegetarian; I'm one of those people,
some people, you know, some men if they're
working at, they really need to like, you
know, protein up and all that stuff. But I
definitely don't believe in that that low
carb stuff, that's like psychotic, I really
don't, and I hate that kind of like obsessive.
I love what I got to do when the guys like,
"I don't need carbs," and I'm like, "Great."
That whole like muscle head, the muscle milk
thing, whatever, anyway, so that's the no
carbs. So, that was my ex fiancée from Chicago,
my own personal moment we're having here,
no carbs at all, no carbs, so.
>> Could you just talk a little bit about
BethennyBakes.
>> FRANKEL: Oh, okay. Oh, because we're on
health products now. Okay, so, all right.
I have a line of--oh, so you're going to get
some today. Are the cookies going to be out?
So I have a line of bakes goods called BethennyBakes,
they're wheat, egg and dairy free and low
fat baked which is sort of ironic because
they came a long time ago and my book talks
about, this book but especially "Skinnygirl
Dish" which is coming out in January. I renovate
recipes, just like I'm a fixologist for cocktails.
I take fattening recipes like macaroni and
cheese, or chicken pot pie or things that
you would normally feel a little bit guilt
eating and make them more healthy, and it's
not that you can't eat regular fattening macaroni
and cheese, it's just that with these healthy
recipes you can have a little bit more of
it, it becomes a better investment, so that's
what BethennyBakes is. There's nothing wrong
with eating a regular chocolate chip cookie
from Mrs. Fields or whoever. But the cookies
happen to be healthy, they have oat flour,
they have apple sauce and bananas, and everything
is like all natural and so, it's actually
a good investment, better than having one
of those bars or something like that and that's
all available on my website. And, the Skinnygirl
Margarita which is coming out, this week we're
launching it and it will be in stores in a
couple of weeks. It's kind of the same thing,
the book talks about you know, I don't want
to say no, every diet I ever went into my
life is like no drinking, and then that would
last like three days. And I always wanted
to have a signature, a drink that I actually
like, but because I was always obsessed of
being on a diet, I would drink clear vodka,
like the flavored raspberry vodka that has
no sugar in it and put a lime in it and pretend
it tasted like raspberries and it really taste
like vodka. And then I would get buzzed and
I wound end up drinking what I wanted which
is a 700 calorie margarita, so I need to create
a margarita that you could trust. So, the
margarita has a hundred calories, it's in
the bottle, the tequila's in the bottle, it's
12.99 a bottle, it's--it's fantastic. It tastes
like you're drinking a margarita from Mexico,
so that's a good thing. And that's kind of
the whole thing. I just want to be, make people
able to indulge and enjoy but have a little
bit less guilt about it, a little bit of less
noise and--hi.
>> Hi. Thank you so much for being at Google.
It's awesome to have you.
>> FRANKEL: Oh, thank you.
>> I was just thinking since you're here,
are you--I know a lot of people go online
to get recipes and things like that and I
know I do it from time to time and like healthy
chicken recipe or whatever I'm searching for.
And I'm just wondering what role you're thinking
about taking there online?
>> FRANKEL: As far as what? As far as…
>> Of having a site where people can get your
recipes or maybe…
>> FRANKEL: I'm working right now. I'm really
making my site way more informational. I mean,
I have a lot of my recipes but they have to
be--I want to be them to be updated on a day
to day basis. I want to keep adding things.
I mean, I don't want to put the things necessarily
that are on my book. I want to put some of
the things in my book. But, I want to make
it much more--I mean, truthfully, all over
the Internet, if you Google, there--all my
recipes end up all over the Internet. And,
I use Google for every recipe that I've created,
I'll say that, you know, I'll say to the girls
that Google me, you know, a regular fattening
like red velvet cake. And it's all an equation
and my second, let's not talk about a second
book but the second book, "Skinnygirl Dish"
teaches people to think about their refrigerator
or kitchen like a closet. We have like a black
dress and you have to accessorize it rather
than you have to go out and buy a whole brand
new outfit. Or go and buy a whole shopping
list for recipe, so I'll go on Google and
I'll be like, "All right, oh no, look at my
kitchen" I'm like, "Do we have three brown
bananas. What am I going to make?" I'll look
on Google and I'll be like, "Banana bread."
And I'll start substituting things out and
make a low fat, healthy versions of it and
everything's been like a total chemistry equation
and pretty much like 70% of them end up working
and 30% flop. I mean, the whole second book
is about teaching people how to think for
themselves in the kitchen and not have to
be a slave to recipe. So, I do want to have
my website be more informational, like if
you follow me on Twitter, we do contests every
week. If whoever comes up with the best recipe
to go with the Skinnygirl Margarita or, you
know, I ask a lot of different questions because
I want to know what people want in a book,
so we give out, you know, free case of margaritas
or a Skinnygirl basket of things. So, yeah,
I do want to have to be more, that more of
informational website with recipes and things
that that... Oh the website is bethenny.com,
or for the cocktails at skinnygirlcocktails.com
but truthful themly, thank you guys, Google,
because every single time I go to look up
a fattening recipe that I want to renovate
or a cocktail because I want--I was doing
triple crown cocktail so I came up with--I
had to do the Black-Eyed Susan and the mint
julep and renovate them. I went to Google
for every single--we live on Google. Who doesn't,
though, I mean it's not like I'm a special.
I lived on Google. I'm not a, you know, I'm
not--totally.
>> Hi Bethenny, thank you so much for coming.
We knew we had to come late so I bought four
copies of your book yesterday.
>> FRANKEL: Oh, thank you.
>> I have two questions. One is less serious.
Do you go on YouTube? And if so, what are
your favorite YouTube videos?
>> FRANKEL: I don't go YouTube. I like--I
don't go unless someone says, sent something
to me. I love that one about them; I love
that new one with them dancing in the wedding.
I love the one, what's the one in the wilderness
with the animals are fighting?
>> [INDISTINCT]?
>> FRANKEL: What's that?
>> The battle of Cougar Park.
>> What is that?
>> FRANKEL: Yes. I love that, I love that
baby. I could listen that baby laughing.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> FRANKEL: The baby laughing forever. But
I don't go that--I'm not that--I really do
go to Google every minute of the day just
getting information. I mean, but I don't really--I
don't like, I don't scour the Internet. I
mean, I Google work to myself when I barely
look at them, they look at them but I'm not
that much of the Internet person. I don't
use my computer that much. I'm more of a Blackberry
person, so.
>> And then a serious question. We talked
a lot about eating. I remember you guys did
yoga in one of the shows. What do you do for
exercise? And how was that change overtime?
>> FRANKEL: It's funny--that's a big thing
too. I don't know--I just finished the second
book and it's not been completely edited,
so I don't know if it's going to make it in.
I talk about exercise noise too, how I used
to be obsessed at most times like I would
be in a spinning phase where I'd be spinning
five days a week. And I end up seeing everybody
on the spinning classes and they all end up
looking the same. Nobody ever ends up getting
better, everybody looks the same, and I would
leave them and eat like a wild wolverine because
you're starving, and then you felt guilty
because you ate so much, you have to go back
and spin the next day and it becomes like
a literal, literally you're spinning. And
I'm now much thinner than I've ever been and
I probably work out on the average two to
three, if I'm gone on a weekend vacation,
times a week but I don't have a noise about
it and it's always part of my life. It's like
a friend that you always you know you're going
to go back and see instead of it being like
having an argument with exercise which I used
to, where you go five days a week, be obsessed
and then you completely stop. Or you stop
one or two days, you'd have such guilt about
stopping but then you be like, "I screwed
it up. I'm done, you know, it doesn't matter
anyway," and then you don't go four three
weeks. Now, what happens is I go on a book
tour and I'm not thrilled about the fact that
I'm not exercising, but the first day I get
back if I'm not completely exhausted, I'll
go to yoga with no noise about it. So, it's
a long answer but it is important, it's an
important thing people get into their head
too that if you buy and remember and if you
just had it in your life on some level where--when
I go away for the weekend with my boyfriend,
we have a thing in the morning, we go take
a beach walk. Or last week, we were near this
basketball court, he plays basketball and
I'm like, "Just show me, let's play basketball."
Just to do things like you like whenever you
can and just have a good relationship with
it, that's what I have now. And because I
used to have a crazy with--it's like an ex-boyfriend.
I had a psychotic relationship with him before
and now, now, we can see each other once in
a while and we get along great and I look
just as good as I did then. [INDISTINCT].
>> So, I have a question concerning the work
you do, cooking for celebrities. Two parts:
first, for the celebrities that you, that
are in really good shape and that they're
on camera. Are they generally kind of calorie
obsessed and is that a huge concern or do
you cook more lavishly for them? I just kind
of wonder how that works.
>> FRANKEL: It's funny. Most--I don't really
cook that much for celebrities anymore because
I mean, I do for a specific event but not
regularly because I don't really have the
time that much. It depends--I have never,
I can't really work because of my own issues
with it. Like when I feel someone who has
like a lot of noise about it and is an obsessive
and there's a lot of people like that, but
although I haven't had that done many people
like that request me to cook for them. But
the celebrities that I cook for, they're more
extreme, like I pigged out all summer and
I now I need to get it back for this. And--Dennis
Leary was the opposite. He just was in great
shape. He was playing hockey like three hours
a day and he ate like crap and he felt like
crap so I would just make him meals that he
loves because they were healthy and now, he
has more energy and he looks better. But for
the most part, I find--it's a bit 50-50; 50%,
but they're very extreme and I call them "the
unsustainables." Look at like Jessica Simpson.
Now, she's on a whole big diet or Britney.
Like, you know, even Oprah, like they need
my book. They really do. They need to--no,
they do because they have so--even Oprah,
she has plans to be not be on plans. Like
the new thing with her was I have had too
many plans, you know, I've been in too many
diets, and now, I'm planning to not plan.
I'm going to plan to have more time, not plan
to plan--like it's just, you just need to
just like let it be. And I feel like celebrities
have so much pressure and they feel like,
you know, it's the spotlight is on them and
they're just up and down. So, I've had some
obsessive celebrities and I've had some they
just like to generally eat healthy. It's a
good question because for the most part there,
there's something about it where it's very
up and down and very extreme. And I get it
because that used to be me, and I have not--may
weight hasn't fluctuated and I fought it five
years. I used to fluctuate every five days.
So, I think it's part of being under the spotlight
and having so, so many fads and people throw
things at you and what I've--just like plastic
surgery. This one is doing this, that one
is doing that. So, yeah, I think that's--there's
a huge noisy population of people with celebrities.
>> Cool. Thanks. Who is the coolest celebrity
that you have...?
>> FRANKEL: Dennis Leary is a cool celebrity.
>> Yeah?
>> FRANKEL: Yeah, he is cool. He was fun.
He's, because he's inappropriate and so am
I so, anything flew in that trailer. Cool?
>> Hi.
>> FRANKEL: Hi.
>> So, I wanted to ask you, a lot of us in
the room here are in sales. So, that means
that we spend a lot of time in restaurants.
I don't know if you noticed but we're surrounded
by food.
>> FRANKEL: Yes.
>> In this environment.
>> FRANKEL: I know. I just had some of that
strawberry special cake. It was good, I never
had it before.
>> Right, and was that planned?
>> FRANKEL: What?
>> I mean, who knew when that was going to
be there, right?
>> FRANKEL: Right.
>> It's just shows up.
>> FRANKEL: Right. Yeah, I had a bowl of granola,
I would have shot myself years ago if I ate
a whole bowl of granola. I would have been
in therapy; I would not have been able to
speak now. I mean, I just want to. I mean,
yeah, you guys--
>> I just wanted to know if you had any advice
for those of us who seemed to find ourselves
just surrounded by food like other second.
>> I'm surrounded by food all the time. I'm
in a restaurant every night, I don't--it doesn't
matter if you're surrounded by food. It doesn't
matter if you're on a cruise ship. It doesn't
matter if you're on vacation, it doesn't matter
if you go out to the most fattening restaurant,
Chinese restaurant too, you know, eat fried
chicken, southern, you know, southern restaurant.
When I'm in Charlotte, North Carolina, and
I want to go to the barbeque place, you just
can't, we will read the book and it will make
sense to you. So what if you're around food?
I mean, no offense to the group, like there
was cereal. Like I haven't seen a cereal some--I
eat can eat cereal anytime like I need to
eat those cereal, I mean, it was good, it
was fine. Tomorrow I wouldn't be like, "Oh,
I need to eat those strawberry special cakes."
I mean, it wasn't like, you know, there was
a carving station and like [INDISTINCT] come
in, you know, and a cotton candy machine,
it wasn't like crazy. It was good. But, you
know, you're an adult. It's your choice, you
decide. If you want to eat five bowls of cereal,
then decide what you're not going to have
tonight when you go out to a great restaurant
to have steak. Like, you're--I'm a grown woman
and you could be surrounded by food and--no,
I'm just saying like--I didn't mean to beat
you, I'm just saying like it's good. Walk
away and be like I had a bowl of cereal, it
was fine and it was good and I'm done. It
just has to be--what? Well, that's here. She's
just talking about here surrounded by food.
Right, now, I'm going to talk about--thank
you, Larry. So, that's being in a place like
here where it's just always around. But you'll
see, you kind of get sick of it and boredom
too. Do something else but just--but--I don't
want to say to have any rules or anything,
but, you know, portions are good. In my own
house, I have little ramequins, you know,
I have a cereal bowl, it was a big cereal
bowl, have your cereal in a cup like, and
don't have to be in some big group thing where
you're grabbing because that's just grounds
for not knowing what you're doing. You want
to kind of be conscious of what you're doing,
so I'd say using the, the little like a espresso
cup you had, for things, just a portion, now
to kind of have an idea, where not obsessing
about it. But what--because you're in sales
and you're probably taking people out, I would
assume. Restaurants I find are easier than
home because you have portions there and there
is some sort of control. So, I'm a person,
if I go to a restaurant, I don't look at the
main course area. I find it to be--it's going
to be a big giant commitment to this big thing
and this thing, I like the appetizers. So,
I'll pick like a salad or a healthy appetizer
and then a fattening appetizer, something
I would never have allowed myself to eat before.
Like a fried calamari or like a crab cake
or something, and have two appetizers and
go to the side sections. So, that was always
like appetizers on the side and pick the greens,
you're not going to get creams--it's not you
can't have a bite of it even if someone gets
it. Pick up the sausage and spinach, get some
mushrooms and fill yourself up on the higher
volume foods and make rules for yourself.
Just loose rules like for two drink maximum,
that's clear liquor, but if you decide you
want dessert, it's a bank account. Have one
drink and then have a couple of bites of the
dessert. You just have a constant conversation
about what's going on that's not noisy and
it's not tallying; it's just knowing. You
know, I want that bread. Somebody had a half
a piece of the bread, zip in a oil, you feel
like one of those bread eating people now;
you're not one of the people that's afraid
of bread. So you have a little bit of the
bread and then, you know, maybe a couple of
bites of the dessert--this could be a taste
everything eat nothing moment. But it could
be a good investment thing when you're starving,
so here's where you're having sautéed fish
and brown rice and investing well and not
having all that other stuff. Each moment is
its own moment. It could be me maybe on plane
and being like I'm dying for chocolate, some
of have half a Three Musketeers and a handful
of nuts, to balance it out, and it's all in
the book. And that's what's happening here,
but it shouldn't be something that's general;
every single minute every day. One day you
might eat terribly and just feel like four
o'clock, you've eating more food than you've
eaten in four days. And it happens, but don't
have noise about it, just--it is what it is.
>> Thanks.
>> FRANKEL: Thanks. I feel like I abused her.
I was abused, I like abused her. I'm sorry,
you didn't come her to get beaten' up, everybody
loves you. Jesus loves you. She's like, "I
don't want to come back to the Google meetings,
they were mean to me there." Oh. Oh, do I
sign downstairs? Oh, okay, we're going to
sign books downstairs--upstairs. Thank you
guys so much for having me and taking time
out of your day, this was so great, and I'm
so happy to be here. Thank you.